so the january 6 committee may have
uncovered some pretty serious crimes
after nearly a year of investigating the
january 6 attack on the us capital the
house select committee has started to
present their findings to the american
people in a series of televised hearings
since its formation the committee has
conducted over a thousand interviews and
reviewed more than 140 000 documents the
committee has also issued more than 100
subpoenas for testimony and documents as
part of its inquiry from a variety of
individuals including republican members
of congress former trump white house
officials outside trump allies like
roger stone and alex jones and white
nationalist figures who've promoted
false election claims the committee has
presented a trove of evidence suggesting
that the trump white house not only
deliberately undermined american
democracy but might have committed
crimes in the process and the committee
has even told the federal court that it
believes the former president himself
could be criminally prosecuted for his
conduct leading up to and his actions on
january 6 2021 but what are the
potential crimes that former president
trump and his cadre might have committed
related to january 6. well there are a
lot of them and we're going to go into
detail for each one now this is not an
exhaustive survey since the one six
committee isn't finished yet it's also
fairly one-sided because it is not a
criminal prosecution and it's not
adversarial so it's one side's
presentation though many of the
witnesses are former trump confidants so
take that for what you will but in 2020
then president donald trump was defeated
for reelection by former vice president
joe biden by a margin of 7 million
popular votes and a count of 306 to 232
votes in the electoral college since his
loss president trump has falsely
insisted the election was stolen from
him while repeating ridiculous debunks
conspiracy theories now these false
accusations were endorsed by many
republican members of congress and
supporters in the media now between
election day and inauguration day
president trump and his allies sought to
overturn the results by filing over 62
lawsuits where they lost every single
one but a tiny part of one
case involving proximity to ballots
and made repeated allegations of
election fraud in the news and social
media organized protests and tried to
convince legislators to take part and
pressure georgia's secretary of state to
find enough votes to carry that
particular state in addition 84
republicans signed legal documents
falsely claiming to be the duly chosen
electors for donald trump in the
electoral college despite trump having
lost in those particular states these
include dozens of local republican party
leaders seven candidates for public
office eight current office holders and
at least five previous state and federal
office holders this fake elector scheme
was led in part by rudy giuliani and
trump lawyer john eastman the latter of
whom penned two now public memos to
pressure vice president mike pence to
overthrow the election results and on
january 6 2021 a mob of trump supporters
stormed to the u.s capitol to disrupt a
joint session of congress that had
convened to certify the results of the
2020 election prior to that attack
president trump encouraged a large crowd
of his supporters near the white house
to march on the us capitol and quote
fight like hell to resist
congress's certification of the biden
victory which many in the crowd did
and approximately 140 capital and
metropolitan police officers were
criminally assaulted in the attack one
died of a series of strokes after being
hospitalized for his injuries sustained
in the attack and two others committed
suicide one of the riders was shot and
killed by the police another died of a
heart attack and a third was crushed to
death by the stampeding mob riders
caused about 1.5 million dollars in
damages to the capitol building and in
response the house of representatives
with 10 republican votes impeached trump
for incitement of insurrection mr trump
was acquitted after only 57 senators 10
short of the required two-thirds
majority voted to find him guilty and
even after the carnage on january 6
trump continues to falsely claim that
the election was stolen from him it's
all over the place it's massive election
fraud and in may of 2021 senate
republicans blocked the passage of a
house passed bill that would have
created a national commission to
investigate the january 6 attack in
response the house voted to create a
select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the us capital
speaker pelosi rejected the appointments
of republican representative jim jordan
and jim banks citing their objections to
the election results on january 6 and
raising concerns that they would impact
the integrity of the investigation in
response house minority leader kevin
mccarthy pulled all remaining
republicans on the committee though
pelosi still named two impeachment
supporting republicans liz cheney and
adam kinzinger to serve on the select
committee now much of the past year has
involved the prosecution of over 800
january 6 rioters with charges ranging
from obstruction of an official
preceding assault to seditious
conspiracy but the january 6 hearings
are looking up the ladder to see what
crimes and to what extent the trump
white house its allies and even trump
himself were responsible for on that day
so let's look at some of the potential
criminal violations of trump and his
circle now we first begin with criminal
conspiracy to defraud the united states
under 18 usc 371 it is a criminal
offense quote if two or more persons
conspire either to commit any defense
against the united states or to defraud
the united states or any agents thereof
in any manner or for any purpose the
supreme court has held the statute
criminalizes the use of deceptive
practices in connection with quote any
conspiracy for the purpose of impairing
obstructing or defeating the lawful
function of any department of government
and conspiring to obstruct a joint
session of congress from certifying the
election certainly qualifies as seeking
to obstruct a lawful function of the
government now to convict someone of
defrauding the united states the
government must establish three elements
one at least two people entered into an
agreement with the specific intent to
obstruct a lawful function of government
two the individuals used deceitful or
dishonest means to accomplish this goal
and three at least one of the
conspirators engaged in at least one
overt act in furtherance of the
agreement and to establish the requisite
intent for this crime it's sufficient
for the prosecution to prove that the
defendant knew that the statements were
false or fraudulent when made and that
such statements disrupted the functions
of the government accordingly the
january 6 committee has laid out a
seven-point plan for how trump and his
allies orchestrated to defraud the
united states government one they
engaged in a concerted effort to spread
false information to the american public
that the 2020 election was stolen two
they orchestrated a corrupt scheme
between trump his chief of staff mark
meadows and representative scott perry
to replace the acting attorney general
who rejected trump's fraud claims with
trump doj ally jeffrey clark to use the
justice department to overturn the
election three they implemented a plan
by attorney john eastman in two now
public legal memos to pressure vice
president pence to refuse to count or
delay the certification of the electoral
count despite eastman's knowledge that
this violated federal law four they
pressured state election officials and
state legislators to change election
results like trump's infamous january
second call to georgia's secretary of
state brad raffensberger to quote find
enough votes to flip the state's results
five they instructed republicans
including chief of staff mark meadows
acting at trump's behest in multiple
states to embrace rudy giuliani and john
eastman's plan to create a false
electoral slate in seven battleground
states and transmit those fake slates to
congress and the national archives six
they summoned assembled and incited a
violent mob in washington and directed
them to march on the u.s capitol and
seven during the attack trump ignored
pleas for assistance failed to take
immediate steps to stop the violence and
even appeared to tacitly endorse the
violence including threats to hang mike
pence
now it appears that the phony elector
scheme has caught the doj's attention
having issued subpoenas to several
individuals who signed false
certificates including the chairs of the
georgia and arizona republican party and
in a march 2022 crime fraud exception
ruling california federal judge david
o'carter found quote it is more likely
than not that trump and eastman
conspired to defraud the united states
by corruptly attempting to obstruct the
counting of electoral votes on january
6. but it remains to be seen whether the
doj will bring formal charges against
former president trump and his allies
related to section 371 but that takes us
to obstructing an official proceeding of
congress under 18 usc 1512. now that
criminalizes the obstruction or
attempted obstruction of an official
proceeding with a maximum prison
sentence of 20 years to obtain a
conviction prosecutors must establish
that the person obstructed influenced or
impeded or attempted to obstruct
influence or impede an official
proceeding of the united states and did
so corruptly courts have uniformly held
that the january 6 joint session is an
official proceeding and hundreds of
capital riders have been charged with
this crime and for many this is the only
felony that they were charged with this
includes jacob chansley the so-called q
anon shaman who pleaded guilty to a
single charge of corruptly impeding an
official proceeding and was sentenced to
41 months in prison now the legal theory
for prosecution is that former president
trump in concert with allies like
eastman clark meadows and others
intentionally or corruptly interfered
with congress's certification of
electoral votes despite aggressive
pushback that not only were these plans
illegal but that there was no reasonable
basis to doubt that biden won now
multiple members of trump's circle
testified under oath to the select
committee that they all told trump his
claims of election fraud were baseless
including attorney general bill barr
campaign aide jason miller mike pence's
former chief of staff mark short and
even his own daughter ivanka and though
trump's circle told him his claims were
baseless his supporters took those
claims as gospel to justify storming
capital to deny certification i'm here
to protest this corruption
we want to stop the steal we want a free
election we want donald trump in office
the committee's first hearing on january
9th showed previous unseen footage of
riders many whom said they were
following president trump's commands to
storm the capital to block the
certification of election they were told
was stolen and people are really pissed
off because we know how much cheating
took place if he would have won fair and
square i think we would be fine but we
can't let them overthrow our country and
the mob believing these election lies
did successfully delay the count for at
least seven hours by violently forcing
both chambers into recess and hiding
trump's reported obstruction scheme also
involved strong arming the doj to
overturn the election and
contemporaneous notes of acting deputy
attorney general richard donahue showed
that trump asked him directly to quote
say that the election was corrupt and
leave the rest to him and the republican
congressman
suggesting that trump didn't want a good
faith investigation just a doj declaring
as cover for throwing out biden's duly
elected electoral votes and accordingly
the select committee has presented
evidence that trump and others corruptly
obstructed an official proceeding by
advancing legal strategies they knew
were unlawful based on allegations of
election fraud and they had no
reasonable basis to believe that they
were true but prosecution under section
1512 depends on how federal courts
interpret that statute in march of 2022
dc judge carl nichols a trump appointee
who has issued more lenient january 6th
sentences compared to his colleagues
broke with at least seven other dc
federal judges by ruling that the doj
cannot charge individuals with
obstructing congress unless the
defendants actually tampered with
official documents or records on january
6. so this could potentially impact
hundreds of cases including the
potential prosecution of trump and his
circle and that takes us to garden
variety wire fraud between election day
and leaving office on january 20th 2021
then president trump raised hundreds of
millions of dollars for what he told
supporters was to contest the results
there's just one 250 million dollar
problem trump raised millions for an
election defense fund that may not
actually exist some have suggested this
could be wire fraud under 18 usc 1343
wirefraud occurs when someone uses
interstate communications devices like a
cell phone a computer or other
electronic device to advance a scheme to
defraud another to proof wire fraud the
government has to establish four
elements one that the defendant
voluntarily and intentionally devised or
participated in a scheme to defraud
another out of money that the defendant
did so with the intent to defraud that
it was reasonably foreseeable that
interstate wire communications would be
used and that interstate wire
communications were in fact used to
convict trump of wire fraud prosecutors
would have to show that he solicited
funds for one purpose and knowingly used
them for another the january 13th
hearing led by congresswoman zoe lofgren
of california showed that the campaign
spent very little of this money on
election contests and instead funneled
the money to among other destinations
trump business properties and his own
save america political action committee
this fundraising scheme might
potentially be fraudulent not just
because it induced donations with claims
of voter fraud which trump had been
repeatedly informed by the justice
department and others that they were
baseless but also because the money did
not go to where people thought it was
going to go this would be a particularly
hard claim to prove but there is
precedent for prosecuting candidates who
raise money for fake organizations and
then spend the funds on themselves in
2019 harold russell taub a rhode island
republican who ran unsuccessfully
against democratic congressman david
cicilline in 2016 pleaded guilty to wire
fraud and campaign finance violations in
connection with a 1.6 million dollar
raise for a non-existent political
action committee in the course of
fundraising taub told his donors that
his pac staff were volunteers and that
100 percent of the donations would be
used to support republican candidates in
ohio at the state and federal level in
reality the two packs were unregistered
and taub spent one million dollars of
those funds on personal expenses adding
to the deception taub falsely told
donors that he was an ambassador and
also used without permission
a former secretary of the navy in his
fundraising appeal despite being
repeatedly told to stop taub was
sentenced to three years in federal
prison in order to repay 1.1 million
that he made through his fraudulent
pacts now ironically trump's best
defense against wirefraud would be to
argue that he sincerely did believe that
the funds would be used to fight
election contests and for the mercurial
and potentially sincere donald trump
that could be a challenge for
prosecutors but that takes us to
criminal solicitation to commit election
fraud and other georgia state crimes now
it seems like trump is particularly
vulnerable to a litany of state charges
in georgia where fulton county district
attorney fannie willis has convened a
special grand jury to investigate trump
and his allies efforts to pressure
election officials and change the vote
count in georgia by letter dated
february 10 2021 d.a willis announced
that her office had quote opened an
investigation into attempts to influence
the administration of the 2020 general
election and where trump and his allies
probably find the most potential
criminal exposure is georgia code
section
21-2-604 the criminal solicitation to
commit election fraud which can be
charged as either a misdemeanor or
felony and to establish a violation
under section 21-2-604
the d.a has to show that the defendant
has one solicited requested commanded
importuned or otherwise attempted to
cause another person to engage in
election fraud and two the defendant
actually intends for the other person to
commit election fraud and at the center
of this potential crime are the two
recorded phone calls involving the
president applying pressure to state
election officials to flip the state
from biden to himself
first on december 23 2020 trump urged
francis watson the chief election
investigator for georgia's secretary of
state office to find fraud telling her
quote
when the right answer comes out you'll
be praised and second in the famous
january 2nd 2021 recorded phone call to
georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger where the former president
famously demanded that he quote fined 11
780 votes one more than trump needed to
win in that state i just want to find
11
780
[Music]
votes which is one more that we have
when raffensberger rejected trump's
false claims of voter fraud like the
demons claimed that the trump votes were
thrown out while suitcases of votes were
carried in for joe biden
trump suggested raffensburger could face
criminal charges telling him it would be
illegal and a big risk to resolve
against reporting trump's false claims
trump also implicitly threatened other
state officials with jail time and
continues to hold a grudge against every
georgia elected official who refuses his
demands so what are we going to do here
folks i only need 11 000 votes fellas i
need 11 000 votes give me a break and in
addition to criminal solicitation of
election fraud d.a willis has indicated
that her office's investigation involves
other potential violations of georgia
law by trump and his associates
including but not limited to
quote the making of false statements to
state and local governmental bodies
that's georgia code section 16-10-20
conspiring to commit election fraud
that's georgia code section 21
dash
2-603 racketeering georgia code section
16-14-4
violation of oath of office section
16-10-1
and any involvement in violence or
threats related to the election
administration that's georgia code
section 21-2-566-597
now illustrating the expanded scope of
the investigation the grand jury has
subpoenaed several key members of the
trump legal team that advised his
campaign on how to overturn biden's wins
in georgia and other swing states
including john eastman clena mitchell
kenneth chesboro jenna ellis and rudy
giuliani who twice presented georgia
state legislators with fake evidence and
wild conspiracy theories even after they
were debunked the grand jury has also
subpoenaed u.s senator lindsey graham
who twice asked raffensberger if there
was any way to throw out mail-in ballots
which were favoring joe biden according
to the subpoena graham asked
raffensberger and his staff a quote
about re-examining certain absentee
ballots cast in georgia in order to
explore the possibility of a more
favorable outcome for trump describing
the call to cnn raffensburger said the
senator was implying that his office
should try to throw away ballots i got
the sense it implied that uh then you
could throw those out but that takes us
to another potential federal charge
which would be the incitement to riot
and insurrection trump was acquitted of
incitement to insurrection in his second
impeachment trial but since that was not
a judicial trial there's no double
jeopardy problem and he could
potentially face charges on various
incitement statutes under the anti-riot
act 18 usc section 2101 anyone who uses
interstate travel to incite organize
participate in or carry on a riot or
commit any other act of violence in
furtherance of a riot or aid or a bet a
person doing the above is guilty of a
federal crime punishable by up to five
years in prison and under section 18 usc
2383
anyone who incites assists or engages in
any rebellion or insurrection against
the authority of the united states or
gives aid or in comfort there too is
subject to up to 10 years in
imprisonment and disqualification from
holding public office now conviction
under either of these statutes would be
incredibly difficult because political
speech tends to be at the very core of
the first amendment and you generally
have a first amendment right to make
these kinds of speeches but in
brandenburg versus ohio the supreme
court established a two-part test for
when the government may criminalize
speech advocating for the use of force
or crime one the speech is directed to
inciting and producing imminent lawless
action and the speech is likely to
incite or produce such action and it
would be incredibly fraught to try to
prove that trump intended to incite uh
imminent lawless action on january 6.
though many writers did say on and after
january 6th they marched on the capital
specifically because trump told them to
i'm here to support
uh the president i think the election
was a fraud and with resect to the
second criteria the committee has
presented evidence that trump not only
incited the mob to go to the capitol but
trump endorsed the violence of the
people he saw when they were there on
his behalf cassidy hutchinson the former
aide to chief of staff mark meadows
provided bombshell testimony that
trump was aware that many people outside
his rally were armed with knives guns in
the form of pistols and rifles bear
spray body armor spears and flagpoles
and he didn't care because they were
quote my people hutchinson further
testified that she heard trump say
something to the effect of i don't care
that they have weapons they're not here
to hurt me take the mags the magnometers
the metal detectors away let my people
in they can march on the capital from
here let the people in take bags away
and hutchinson also testified that when
trump was told about the writer's hang
mike pence chance trump approvingly
responded quote maybe our supporters
have the right idea mike pence deserves
it now furthermore the joint chiefs
chairman general mark milley testified
that pence ordered national guard troops
to defend the capital while trump
allowed the violence to continue
unabated we also know that trump waited
187 minutes before putting out a
statement asking for calm now it was
always going to be a long shot to charge
trump with incitement though
the testimony that has been elicited so
far probably comes as close as
you might be able to get and multiple
sources
say that trump had actual knowledge that
his speech was going to incite his
supporters particularly the armed ones
to go to the capitol before trump
allowed the violence to rage for three
hours
so who knows here but that takes us to
two potential new crimes that were
uncovered witness tampering and
obstruction of justice many people say
it's not the crime it's the cover-up and
that may be the case here as well after
hutchinson's testimony trump ex-chief of
staff mick mulvaney suggested on twitter
that his former boss could be vulnerable
to witness tampering and obstruction of
justice so what would that entail well
18 usc 1512 the same statute that
includes obstruction of an official
proceeding broadly criminalizes witness
tampering with up to 20 years
imprisonment this section makes it a
crime for anyone who knowingly uses
intimidation threats or otherwise
attempts to persuade another person to
change delay or prevent testimony or any
person in an official proceeding after
hutchinson's testimony the select
committee produced examples of witnesses
being asked by people apparently close
to trump to be loyal to him and his
administration representative liz cheney
said an unnamed witness told the
committee quote what they said to me is
as long as i continue to be a team
player they know i'm on the right team
i'm doing the right thing i'm protecting
who i need to protect you know i'll
continue to stay in good graces in trump
world and they have reminded me a couple
of times that trump does read the
transcripts and the second example
cheney cited was a call a witness
received saying quote a person let me
know you have your deposition tomorrow
he wants me to let you know he's
thinking about you he knows you're loyal
and you're going to do the right thing
when you go in for your deposition the
select committee has suggested there are
many more examples of similar efforts to
influence witnesses and with respect to
obstruction of justice 18 usc 1505 that
criminalizes the act or the attempt to
corruptly influence obstruct or impede a
congressional investigation through
threats force or threatening
communications with a penalty of up to
five years imprisonment now corruptly
means acting with an improper purpose uh
personally or by influencing another
including making a false or misleading
statement or withholding concealing
altering or destroying a document or
other information and before her public
appearance hutchinson told committee
that several republican members of the
far-right house freedom caucus asked for
pre-emptive blanket pardons for
themselves and others in connection with
their efforts to overturn the election
including representatives mo brooks matt
gates andy biggs and louis gilmert and
scott perry hutchinson also said jim
jordan asked for an update on
presidential pardons without asking for
one directly and she heard from another
staffer that marjorie taylor green had
asked for a pardon
these preemptive pardon requests could
be an effort to induce those involved or
are witnesses to criminal conduct to
remain silent which even with a
president's nearly unlimited pardon
power might constitute criminal
violations hutchinson also told the
committee that she witnessed meadows
burned documents after a meeting in his
office with representative scott perry
and the destruction of documents coupled
with perry's request for pardon
might suggest the pair understood that
they were doing something illegal which
could be evidence of witness tampering
and or obstruction of justice and that
takes us to seditious conspiracy at the
first hearing of the select committee
representative cheney declared that the
committee will detail plots to commit
seditious conspiracy on january 6th
now this is among the most serious of
crimes alleged with sedition essentially
being just a step below treason to
convict individuals of seditious
conspiracy under 18 usc 2384
prosecutors would have to establish that
at least two people conspired to use
force to overthrow the government oppose
its authority or subvert the execution
of u.s law these charges are
understandably rare but they were
brought against some members of the
far-right oath keepers and proud boys
including their former chairman enrique
terrio for conspiring to use armed force
to violently oppose the peaceful
transfer presidential power so what
might seditious conspiracy charges
against trump or his circle look like
well after the first meeting committee
chair representative benny thompson told
cnn that witnesses had described
conversations between far-right
extremists and trump's circle and direct
communications with oath keepers and
proud boys could be concrete evidence of
white house involvement in the same
crimes it's hard to say we haven't seen
that evidence yet so this conspiracy
might also involve trump and his allies
allowing the violence to continue to
pressure pence and gop law bankers to
accede to the president's demands to not
certify the results
in fact days after the attack we learned
that trump and rudy giuliani urged at
least one gop senator to stall the
proceedings while the violence unfolded
though there are certainly not a lot of
examples of successful seditious
conspiracy prosecutions in the last 100
years though in 1995 sheikh omar abdel
rahman a prominent muslim cleric and
nine others were convicted of seditious
conspiracy for planning to bomb the new
york city landmarks after the 1993 world
trade center bombing so this conspiracy
charges have been difficult to make
stick particularly against far-right
groups given uh the brandenburg
protection of illegal advocacy without
imminent lawless action
but by may 2022 three oath keepers had
pleaded guilty to those charges and if
these defendants cooperated in their
plea deals it might shed light on
whether
members of the trump white house and his
circle could face their own seditious
conspiracy charges and while some might
go to jail others just might get house
arrests in which case their options for
nice home-cooked meals would be limited
but not with today's sponsor hellofresh
hello fresh is a great way to eat
delicious fresh food while still being
healthy even if you have been indicted
for federal crimes in fact hellofresh
has a whole variety of calorie smart and
carb smart recipes as well as
pescetarian and veggie options you can
customize it how you'd like swap out
proteins get premium top of the line
versions hellofresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week so you can
savor these summer flavors right from
home at peak freshness now i'm a
do-it-yourself person i have to say i
was very skeptical when i first heard of
hellofresh because i'm a pretty good
cook so i didn't think that i really
needed the help but i actually loved it
even for an experienced cook hellofresh
delivers new ingredients and recipes
that i'd never try on my own hellofresh
generally keeps everyone's favorite
meals then rotates new ones in all the
time right now they're running their
taste of the summer series with things
like old bay shrimp and sausage boil
family style grilled steak lettuce wraps
or grilled salmon with balsamic tomatoes
now i don't know about you but i'd never
attempt any of those on my own and of
course everything was delivered straight
to my door so i didn't even have to do
any shopping the produce actually gets
to faster than a grocery store so it
arrives with peak freshness and it's
also super easy to save time because
hellofresh cuts out the meal planning
and prep so the recipes only take 20 to
30 minutes to cook literally less time
to cook than it would normally take to
do the shopping itself and it's also
very sustainable since the ingredients
are pre-portioned there's less prep and
less wasted food and the packaging is
almost entirely made from recyclable or
already recycled content hellofresh's
carbon footprint is actually 25 less
than that of meals made from
store-bought groceries and it's 72
cheaper than dining at a restaurant so
if you'd like to try hello fresh and i
recommend that you at least try it you
can go to hellofresh.com and use the
code legaleagle16 for up to 16 free
meals and 3 surprise gifts yes you can
actually get 16 free meals and that
includes free shipping or you can just
click on the link below so again for up
to 16 free meals and three surprise
gifts go to hellofresh.com and use the
code legale16 or just click on the link
below or the one that's on screen right
now and clicking on that link really
helps out this channel so click on this
link or click on this playlist over here
for more legal eagle where i will see
you in court